HISTORY.
THAT'S TONIGHT'S BREAKING NEWS.
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
A BUSY HOUR.
WE START TONIGHT WITH THE
MASSIVE SHAKE-UP AT THE FBI.
REMOVED FROM HIS POSITION AT THE
BUREAU.
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT.
THE TIMING OF McCABE LEAVING THE
THE DAILY BEAST IS REPORTING
THAT McCABE AND JAMES COMEY AND
ROB ROSENSTEIN ARE ALL NAMED IN
THIS 4-PAGE DOCUMENT.
OTHER REPORTING SUGGESTS THAT
THE FBI DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER
WRAY WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
UPCOMING
UPCOMIN
UPCOMING INSPECTOR GENERAL
REPORT.
OUR SOURCES ARE SAYING THAT
McCABE'S EXIT IS THE OPENING OF
A MUCH BIGGER SCANDAL UNFOLDING
IN THE MONTHS AHEAD.
HERE'S WHY.
THAT McCABE QUITTING IS THE
BEGINNING OF MORE RESIGNATIONS
THAT WILL BE COMING.
BEFORE WE DETAIL WHY McCABE
DESERVED TO BE REMOVED.
I WANT TO BE VERY FAR VERY CLEAR
TO THE DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA, THE
POLITICAL BIAS AND CORRUPTION
THAT WE ARE NOW DETAILING AT THE
FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY, IT HAS NOTHING 0 TO
DO WITH RANK-AND-FILE MEMBERS.
THOSE PEOPLE WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO KEEP US SAFE.
THEY DESERVE PRAISE AND SUPPORT
WHICH WE GIVE THEM ON A DAILY
BASIS.
WHO WE ARE FOCUSSING ON IS KEY.
WE ARE EXPOSING A ROGUE GROUP OF
ANDREW McCABE IS ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE.
IT WAS RIGGED.
THE FIX WAS IN.
IT WAS A TOTAL SHAM.
HE OVER-SAW TRUMP HATING FBI
AGENT PETER STRZOK'S WORK ON THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
McCABE IS THOUGHT TO BE THE
CENTRAL POINT OF CONTACT FOR
McCABE ORDERED FBI AGENTS TO
STAND DOWN INTO THE
INVESTIGATION ON THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
McCABE'S WIFE TOOK $700,000
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
VIRGINIA DEMOCRATS IN HER FAILED
STATE SENATE RUN.
AND TRUMP BASHING FBI LOVERS.
STRZOK AND PAGE TEXTED ABOUT THE
INSURANCE POLICY WITH ANDY, WE
BELIEVE THAT'S ANDREW McCABE IN
CASE DONALD TRUMP WON THE
ELECTION WHICH THEY DIDN'T THINK
WOULD HAB.
McCABE IS TIED TO EVERY INSTANCE
OF  CORRUPTION WE ARE EXPOSING.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN FIRED.
McCABE IS JUST THE START.
WE ALSO HAVE HUGE DEVELOPMENTS
TONIGHT.
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
TONIGHT HAS VOTED ALONG PARTY
LINES.
THEY ARE RELEASING TO THE PUBLIC
THAT CLASSIFIED 4-PAGE MEMO THAT
DETAILS MASSIVE FISA ABUSES
AGAINST THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
NO DEMOCRATS VOTED YES.
THE REASON IS THEY DON'T WANT
YOU TO KNOW THE TRUTH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS 5 DAYS TO
APPROVE THE RELEASE SO YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN SEE IT.
MY SOURCES TELL ME THE MATTER IS
BEING TAKEN VERY SERIOUSLY AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT WILL BE REVIEWED IN THE NEXT
48 HOURS.
WHILE THE PRESIDENT BELIEVES IN
TRANSPARENCY HE WILL DELIBERATE
THIS PROCESS.
THE DAILY BEAST REPORTED THAT
ANDREW McCABE, JAMES COMEY AND
ROSENSTEIN ARE ALL NAMED IN THIS
MEMO.
ROD ROSENSTEIN WAS THE OFFICIAL
THAT APPROVED THE WARRANTS TO
SPY OR EXTENDED HEM ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN INTO THE PRETEXT OF
LOOKING AT CARTER PAGE.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS THAT HAVE
SEEN THIS MEMO CALL IT SHOCKING
IT COULD LEAD TO THE END OF THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
THAT'S THAT SERIOUS THAT WE ARE
BEING TOLD IT EXPOSES SEVERE AND
MASSIVE CONSITUTIONAL VIOLATIONS
OF OUR 4TH AMENDMENT.
PRIVACY RATES.
MASSIVE FISA ABUSES.
THIS IS A MAJOR DEVELOPMENT.
THOSE OF YOU THAT CALLED
CONGRESS AND TWEETED AND TEXTED
AND PUTS NOTES ON FACEBOOK TO
RELEASE THE MEMO, YOU SHOULD BE
HAPPY BECAUSE YOU THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE DESERVE TO KNOW ABOUT
THESE ABUSES.
WE WILL HAVE ALL OF THE DETAILS
AS SOON AS WE GET THEM.
ALSO BREAKING THIS HOUR, WE HAVE
A NEWS MEDIA IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT IS OBSESSED WITH CALLING
ONE OF THE BIGGEST SCANDALS IN
AMERICAN HISTORY WITH A MOUNTAIN
OF EVIDENCE AND FACTS SUPPORTING
IT, THEY ARE TRYING TO DISMISS
IT AS A CONSPIRACY.
THE SAME MEDIA NAIFS  THAT WAS
PUSHING BASELESS CONSPIRACY
THREES.
WE HAVE IN EVIDENCE AND THEY
HAVE NONE.
WE PUT THIS MONTAGE TOGETHER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND THOSE
AROUND HIM DURING AN ELECTION
CAMPAIGN COLLUDED WITH A HOSTILE
FOREIGN POWER TO UNDERMINE THE
A POLITICAL HURRICANE IS OUT
PUTIN.
>> THIS IS EVIDENCE OF
WILLINGNESS TO COMMIT COLLUSION.
>> THIS IS OUT RIGHT TREASON.
THERE IS NO QUESTION WHAT HE IS
DOING IS GIVING AID AND COMFORT
TO THE ENEMY.
>> THIS CLOUD ABOUT COLLUSION
WITH RUSSIA WILL HANGOVER HIM.
>> THE ELECTION HACKING IS AT
DO YOU AGREE?
>> COMPLETELY.
>> DONALD TRUMP NOW SITS AT THE
THRESHOLD OF IMPEACHMENT.
>> YOU TOLD THE "WASHINGTON
POST" THERE IS A SMELL OF
TREASON IN THE AIR.
>> PEOPLE ARE AFRAID TO USE THE
T-WORD TREASON.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE ARE
INVESTIGATING.
>> RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
>> A LOT GOING ON.
TRUMP.
WE HAVE SEEN NOTHING SHOWING
TRUMP AND RUSSIAN COLLUSION FOR
A YEAR.
DON'T TAKE HIGH WORD.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE ALLEGE IS THAT THE
RUSSIANS AND THE HACKING OF
DOCUMENTS IN THE ELECTION HAD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN PEOPLE.
I AM NOT PREPARED TO SAY THERE
IS PROOF YOU COULD TAKE TO A
JURY.
>> DO YOU AGREE THAT THE
PRESIDENT REACHED THAT THERE WAS
NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION?
>> WE HAVE NOT SEEN THAT
WHATSOEVER.
WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING THEY HAVE.
THAT HASN'T LED TO THAT.
>> THE LAST TIME WE SPOKE,
SENATORED
SENATORE
SENATOR, I ASKED IF YOU SAW
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION BETWEEN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND THE
RUSSIAN?
YOU SAID NOT AT THIS TIME.
>> THERE HAS BEEN NO CULL
EVIDENCE YET?
>> NO.
>> I DIDN'T SEE ANY SMOKING GUN
ABOUT EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
>> Tucker: NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
THEY DON'T LOOK FOR THE TRUTH.
THEY BELIEVE THEIR OWN LIES.
I THINK MANY CONVINCED
THEMSELVES WITH THE DESTROY
TRUMP MENTALITY THEIR NARRATIVE
IS TRUE WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE.
I HOPE YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
GOING ON.
I WANT TO COMPARE AND CONTRAST.
REAL FACTS AND REAL EVIDENCE
RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
HILLARY CLINTON WE KNOW BROKE
THE LAW BY HAVING A SECRET, TOP
SECRET, SPECIAL ACCESS PROGRAM
AND CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ON
HER SERVER.
THERE ARE A MILLION LAWS.
WE PUT THEM ON THE SCREEN MANY
SO NOBODY COULD GET THEM.
HER AIDES SMASHED THE
BLACKBERRIES WITH A HAMMER.
THOSE ARE FACTS.
WE FOUND OUT TOO THAT PETER
STRZOK, JAMES COMEY AND OTHERS,
THEY PUT THE FIX IN.
WHO WRITES AN EXONERATION BEFORE
AN INVESTIGATION AND BEFORE YOU
THEY CHANGED THE LEGAL STANDARD
IN THEIR MANY EXXON
IN THEIR MANY EXXO
IN THEIR MANY EXONERATION
LETTERS.
THEY CHANGED IT TO EXTREME
CARELESSNESS AND ALTERED
REFERENCES TO CLINTON'S SERVER
BEING HACKED BY HOSTILE ACTORS.
THAT ALLOWED HILLARY CLINTON TO
STAY IN THE PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
THOSE ARE FACTS.
WE KNOW CLINTON CONTROLLED THE
DNC, RIGGED THE PRIMARY AGAINST
BERNIE SANDERS.
IMAGINE IF DONALD TRUMP DID
THAT?
WE DISCOVERED THAT HILLARY
CLINTON TRIED TO RIG THE GENERAL
ELECTION.
USED A LAWYER TO PAY FUSION GPS
OVER $12 MILLION AND CREATE A
PHONEY RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
OBTAIN A FISA WARRANT TO SPY ON
AN OPPOSITION PARTY.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IN AN
ELECTION YEAR AND A PRESIDENT
ELECT.
NEW TEXT MESSAGES EXPOSED THE
ANTI-TRUMP BIAS OF STRZOK AND
PAGE.
THEY TALKED ABOUT THE SO-CALLED
INSURANCE BALANCE WHOM WE
BELIEVE IS ANDREW McCABE WHO WAS
FIRED TODAY.
JULY 1st, BEFORE THEY
INTERVIEWED CLINTON OR BEFORE
COMEY WENT PUBLIC ON JULY 5TH.
LYNCH KNEW THE FIX WAS IN, IN
THE CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
STRZOK, PAGE, AND McCABE AND
COMEY AND LORETTA LYNCH ALL
KNOWING.
THEY WERE HESITANT TO
INVESTIGATE HILLARY CLINTON
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT SHE MIGHT
WIN AND RETALIATE AGAINST THEM.
THAT'S ONLY A SMALL SAMPLING OF
WHAT WAS RELEASED.
THERE IS EVIDENCE PROVING ALL OF
THIS.
WHAT DOES THE MEDIA HAVE TO
PROVE RELATING TO TRUMP AND
RUSSIAN COLLUSION A YEAR LATER?
NOTHING.
NO FACTS.
THEY BASE EVERYTHING ON NOTHING
BUT THEIR OWN CONSPIRACY THEORY
AND THEIR OWN LITTLE MEDIA
AND TELLING THE TRUTH.
THE MEDIA ARE PATHOLOGICAL LIARS
AT A LEVEL WE HAVE NEVER SEEN IN
HISTORY.
LET IT GO.
LAW.
NOR DO THEY CARE ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED